yes hi I'm Asha my question is
considering that Casterly Rock is taller
than every skyscraper built in the 20th
century does it happen to have like a
series of cages and winches or little
elevators or any way to transport things
easily occasionally ruckus loosely based
on the Rock of Gibraltar have you ever
visited the Rock of Gibraltar
it's pretty amazing of course Kesley
rock is bigger and fantasy always turned
everything up to 11 it's not usually
bigger and I hope so they're gonna go
see the rocket you brought them and and
all that it it's pretty amazing their
caves there there there are
fortifications I mean there were there
were gold mines and in in the rocket
revolta they tapped out eventually but
there it's honeycombed with tunnels and
and there are places with a gestation
cannons to repel it and there there's a
whole theatre there and you know no
witches or elevators but landing tunnels
and and steps carved into the rocks
itself and all sorts of other kinds of
cool fashion thank you hi my name is
Jacob I think the beginning of the game
of Thrones
ends with you know all the characters
they all died in the prologue and I was
wondering do you think that's a risky
strategy to open a book that way or you
know what's the best way to hook your
readers or grab your readers by opening
the opening scenes well it worked pretty
well so it can't have been too risky the
result has been pretty good there's no
there's no set set answer to that if
there was one single way to open a book
everybody would be using it and all
books were open the same way but you do
have to hook your you read it and that's
true particularly for new writers I mean
if you're trying to sell your story
short story you're sending out in a
magazine into the anthologies you know
you'd better have a strong opening and a
strong first page or
the editor is going to reject it read
two pages and then bounce it you've got
to get someone interested there and
that's true to some extent of of novels
as well and of the readership when you
when you finally get into the book shops
and the stands if people pick up your
book and they're there standing at a
Barnes & Noble and they're looking
through the stacks and they pick up this
book and that book and they look at the
first page and if they see somebody
intriguing maybe they'll buy the book
can take it home and if not there they
won't now when you get established when
you're in a position that I am or any
you know established author with a long
track record the readers will cut you a
little more slack because the thing that
interests you is there's the name on the
one thing okay it's a Stephen King book
I I know what Stephen came delivers
maybe the first page is look great but I
know he's Stephen King sooner or later
it'll get good but if you don't if
you're not Stephen King and you don't
have a name you better make the
beginning something powerful and
interesting to get the Gator into it or
the book is not gonna be bought and it's
not gonna be read
hi I'm Aziz I have another backstory
question you have created a really
diverse backstory that seems like it
just merges with the main story so well
that it kind of gets hard to keep track
of which is which at some point which is
a good thing I wanted to ask about the
character bittersteel Darrin the second
was a king who tried to bring peace to
the realm and it's said that he tried to
keep the great bastards close and we
kind of have examples of what he did for
Damon and for Brendan rivers but we're
not really sure what he did to keep
bitter still close obviously didn't work
but curious what he tried to do well I
may explore all of this in future things
especially blood and Fire that history
eternity looking for that women with
rain but it'll be awhile before I
actually write that it you know one of
the things I'm doing with these things
is exploring a concept of what
constitutes is Goodin a good and bad
King
and the our viewpoint is modern 21st
century people is I think different from
what medieval people were particularly
medieval novels medieval people would
think you know you look at a king like
edward ii of england
he was the son of Edward the first
Longshanks the hammer of the Scots the
Conqueror of Wales who expanded the
things but edward ii he was a big
strapping guy as big as his father blond
very handsome strong athletic but he was
not inclined to warfare and he didn't
like jousting or swordplay which is not
to say that he was bookish or sedentary
he he liked wrestling and he liked
working with his hands he liked building
things and carpentry and fetching rules
and all that and he didn't like the
Lords of the realm who he found arrogant
and obnoxious but he liked the common
people he liked to go out into the
villages and associated with common
people he surrounded themselves with the
commoners who were were carpenters or
stonemasons and he was interested in the
crafts and how they did their crafts and
we would look at a guy like that and say
hey this is a pretty cool guy what the
history is he's despised he's considered
the worst King England over has now it
there's also a big case that he was he
was gay he was homosexual which is
probably part of it and you know because
many many of his associates were young
men and fatigue to particular favors
piers Gaveston and so forth but
nonetheless being warlike in the 21st
century is not necessarily a good thing
but it was considered necessary for King
back then and you know I'm looking at
the the same exponents of recent issues
in in Westeros you know King Daeron the
second Darren the good was not a warlike
King
he was more of an intellectual and he
was interested in peaceful solutions to
problems he was interested in producing
economic growth and and the prosperity
of his realm but he was surrounded by
these bastards his father's other sons
who who were much more formidable
swordsmen and warriors and jousters and
who are interested in conquest and glory
and those are the things that people
responded to in those days let's just
hope that the president American
electorate doesn't go all medieval in
the next election we can see some of
these candidates trying to you know yeah
win votes by saying how many people they
would carpet-bomb or how tough they
would be you know and I was wondering if
you had read Robert Jordans Wheel of
Time series and fabrics some of them you
know he was he was writing those and I
discovered that I was forgetting a lot
so I I stopped reading them and to wait
until he finished and of course they he
unfortunately passed away before he said
it Brandon Sanderson is finished but I
haven't caught up with Dean I think I've
read about four of the books and I'm
about eight behind huh did you read it
to have a favorite character and that
series a favorite character but he had
the three main kids who were one and and
I think I like the one who was parent I
think was okay yeah the three main guys
the one I like the most
okay thank you okay grant did have three
women which was probably a good thing I
guess I ran anyway
surely for the three women yes hi my
name's Jerry I'm a gamer by trade and I
was wondering one of the things that
you've done you've had several video
games come out the telltale series of
Game of Thrones the Game of Thrones
Genesis the strategy game you've had
tabletop role-playing games you've had
card games what's it like from a
technical or a from the writers
perspective of creating for these kind
of properties he said how much how
different is it how like is it and how
much do you enjoy it compared to just
actually write out books well I don't
actually get involved in creating the
games I recognize the synchronicity you
know I'm a book writer and it helps me
to have these products out there I know
many people have come to read my books
through the television show but there's
also a certain number of come to me from
the game they played the Fantasy Flight
card game record game or they played the
the telltale game or a cyanide video
game - preceded it and they've gotten
interested in the world that bought my
books but I have a hard enough time just
doing the books done I don't have time
to start inventing the games - so my
role in the games is sometimes I have a
role particularly in selecting apart
because I'm fussy about wanting the best
fantasy art and so I I name artists that
I want to work with and all that but I
don't get involved in inventing in the
game rules or the scenarios you know
that sometimes some of the game
companies will have me involved as on
the approval basis they'll send me what
they've come up with and I can approve
or disapprove or get notes but for the
most part I let them handle that running
in
to it myself do you still have a given
group in New Mexico yeah we do but it's
not very active these days a couple
people moved away and you know I don't
know it's not if you play much anymore
in the last game we really played
regularly was the one that it ultimately
became the expanse TV series come on and
Ty Frank was running that for us and
when he and Daniel decided they would
make that a series of books in the TV
show I stopped running the game which
was a pity because I was really enjoying
that game yeah my question is this Hodor
[Laughter]
[Applause]